was there ever a point that you started
thinking this is wrong
and i don't want to do this anymore for
me while
the abuse was going on so the abuse for
me went from
age 7 to 14 years old i remember
feeling around 12 starting to be a
little more uncomfortable
about that and sometimes maybe trying to
change the subject or
you know distract but then
but then having a fear that
if i don't do this i'm already feeling
like i'm not
a favorite of michael's anymore and if i
don't do this
what's going to happen what's going to
happen to our friendship yeah
yeah you were worried about losing the
friendship yeah in a strange way the
sexual stuff
became the safe zone right in within the
relationship
meaning the thing that would the
grounding source
of the relationship because that's what
it became
so quickly you know and that
was such an obvious
reason or part of the connection why
were together and why
he wanted me around was to get to that
get to the sexual stuff the jackson
family points out to us that your
stories changed after michael's death is
what they're saying
um they also believe that if you were
still alive you all would not be sitting
here talking to us right now
what do you say to them i mean it's hard
to
speculate as to what would be the
situation if michael's
is still alive if
i guess if i could speculate if michael
was still alive and all of the other
rest of the details of my life were the
same meaning
i became a father right and i went
through the same
process that i did of this realization
and going through the healing process
my belief is that we'd still be doing
this of course some details may be
different
james i i don't yeah i don't know um
would i've taken this to my grave i
certainly planned on doing that
so the documentary you said you planned
on taking it to your grave right so i
had
no expectations of ever telling anyone
so
you know if he if he was still alive
yeah i don't know maybe i would have
taken it to my grave
you